Miami is dealing with gusts of up to 60
miles an hour mark Strassmann is in
downtown Miami and is having trouble
just standing up mark good morning
things that are flying around this is
that this branch is one there's a downed
power line back there that is a spark
behind me that trust me I'm keeping a
close eye on I'm thinking now about
holdouts
people who've made the decision to ride
out the storm this area miami-dade
County largest evacuation order in this
state's history of all the Hurricanes
that have come and gone
more people were ordered to evacuate
them than ever before six hundred and
seventy thousand people but you know
that there are a number of people who
decided to fight it out just keeping an
eye on that thing too has to be scary
wins the rains and this is just the
beginning of it this is going to be
simple very very nerve-wracking in some
cases terrifying hours from people
coming at my hotel today
you couldn't sleep because of the wind
the noise and the anxiety he was heading
up to have a cigarette to call himself
and he was in a fairly safe place
someplace that is not nearly as safe and
you've got serious ii doubts i mean that
is going to be that has got to be a very
furry roll the dice and now regret you
guys mark thanks anybody who's ever been
in the middle of a hurricane says to me
it's much worse than you imagined yeah i
mean just looking at those pictures and
i think Charlie that those were only 60
mile an hour winds wait till it gets
where it's expected to be well over a
hundred miles it's very scary